Dans le matin glacé du désert libyen,
Pascal Le Toubou fait une pause,
avant une longue journée de route.
Comme tous
les hommes de sa tribu,
il connaît cette mer
de sable comme sa poche.
Indispensable dans son métier.
Pascal est
un passeur d'immigrés.
Toutes les semaines,
il conduit des clandestins
qui arrivent de toute
l'Afrique vers le haut, comme il dit,
vers la Méditerranée.
Demain matin,
Pascal et son assistant ont
deux Camerounais à convoyer.
Un voyage périlleux
qu'il vaut mieux bien préparer.
La voiture doit être en parfait état.
Pas question de tomber
en panne dans le désert.
Pour conjurer le sort,
Pascal a un grigri.
Et pour le moral,
deux bouteilles de gin.
Mais, le plus important
est d'être bien armé.
Depuis la révolution,
le gouvernement libyen a du mal
à reprendre le contrôle de son pays.
Il faut pouvoir se défendre
contre les bandits de grands chemins
qui pullulent dans le désert.
Ce sont des roquettes.
Pascal habite la ville
la plus au sud de la Libye,
Mourzouq,
une oasis de 20 000 habitants.
Depuis la mort de Kadhafi en 2011,
la Libye est devenue le principal corridor
de l'immigration clandestine.
Des centaines d'Africains illégaux
viennent s'échouer dans ses rues.
Mourzouq est une ville étape.
Les clandestins s'y arrêtent
pour se refaire une santé financière.
Ils gagnent ici
quelques centaines d'euros.
De quoi payer la suite
de leur voyage vers l'Europe.
C'est exactement
le parcours des deux clients de Pascal.
Ce matin,
c'est le grand départ.
L'assistant
du passeur vient les réveiller.
Émile,19 ans, sans diplôme,
est parti de son pays
à l'âge de 16 ans.
Élie, 24 ans,
footballeur professionnel.
Tous deux vont risquer
leur vie pour un rêve,
rejoindre
la France coûte que coûte.
Leur dangereux
périple a commencé en 2010.
Tous les deux ont quitté
leur pays natal, le Cameroun,
avant de passer
par le Tchad, où ils se sont rencontrés.
Une lente avancée de trois ans,
pour finalement échouer à Mourzouq,
où ils sont devenus maçons
pour payer la suite de leur voyage.
En France, Élie compte
bien redevenir le grand sportif
qu'il était dans son pays.
Il fallait qu'on trouve
un moyen pour que je sorte du pays.
Les problèmes de visa au Cameroun,
surtout pour la France,
ce n'est pas très évident.
Mon souhait, c'est d'être
dans le show-biz, le show business.
C'est ce que
j'adore le plus au monde.
Après son bac, Émile a fait
un stage à la télé camerounaise.
Réussir dans le show-biz
en France, est devenu une obsession.
Quand il parle de Paris,
il a des étoiles plein les yeux.
Je vois la France
le plus souvent à la télé.
Des grands immeubles,
les Champs-Élysées.
Les gens sont libres,
s'expriment comme ils veulent,
se promènent
comme ils veulent.
Il y a du travail,
il y a tout ce que je veux.
Il y a ça là-bas en France,
donc je souhaite vraiment y aller.
Après deux ans
passés à Mourzouq,
leurs deux existences
se résument à cette simple valise.
On voyage en combattants,
comme ça a toujours été, dès le début.
C'est deux
ou trois fringues pour la route.
Oui. Allez, go !
Ce matin-là,
ils sourient, mais leur rêve
est soudain devenu terrifiant.
Ils vont affronter 2 000 kilomètres.
D'abord le désert,
et surtout la mer Méditerranée,
qu'ils vont traverser
sur un bateau de fortune.
Allez,
il faut monter, monte !
L'assistant de Pascal
prend place à l'arrière.
Toi, pareil, il faut descendre
dès qu'il y a une panne après.
Le long voyage démarre
sur les chapeaux de roue
car Pascal,
le passeur, est un peu éméché.
Il multiplie les coups d'accélérateur.
Les deux
Camerounais restent confiants.
On est contents
de partir, on est aussi tristes
d'avoir laissé
tout le reste de nos compagnons
avec qui
on a passé du temps ensemble.
Il y a la fierté, mais
c'est aussi un peu mêlé de tristesse.
Le cœur serré,
Élie enregistre un dernier message
que l'assistant remettra
aux copains restés à Mourzouq.
Chaque fois que
tu auras un problème,
un événement
malheureux ou heureux,
tu peux compter sur nous.
Nous sommes tes frères.
Ce n'est que la mer
qui nous sépare
et j'espère que très bientôt
on va se revoir.
Pour atteindre Paris,
les deux jeunes Camerounais
vont prendre
des risques insensés.
Comme Émile et Élie,
ils seraient près de 150 000,
chaque année,
à vouloir franchir les frontières
illégalement,
pour rejoindre ce qu'ils croient
être l'eldorado européen.
Seuls ou en famille,
ils sont prêts à prendre tous les risques
pour y arriver,
quitte à perdre la vie.
Ils viennent
d'Afrique et d'Orient.
Pour la première fois,
des caméras de télévision ont suivi
pendant un an,
le parcours incroyable de ces migrants.
Avec Émile et ses compagnons,
nous avons franchi les déserts,
traversé la Méditerranée
sur un bateau de fortune
au fond d'une cale,
dans des conditions inhumaines
comme
les esclaves d'autrefois.
Un enfer, plus que l'enfer.
Avec Javid, Lukman
et leurs amis afghans,
nous avons gravi des montagnes
et passé des frontières interdites.
croisé des passeurs sans pitié,
bravé le froid, la faim et la soif.
Il reste combien
de montagnes à traverser ?
Tout ça.
-Tout ça ?!
Tous n'atteindront pas la France.
C'est leur terrible histoire
que nous allons vous raconter.
Dans la voiture qui emmène
Élie et Émile vers la Méditerranée,
le mélange est détonnant,
musique, alcool et pied au plancher
les emporte à 180 kilomètres par heure.
Ça, c'est Wenge Musica,
voilà un groupe d'Afrique.
D'un seul coup,
Pascal quitte la nationale.
Le goudron,
comme on dit en Afrique.
Il emprunte des pistes que seuls
les hommes du désert connaissent.
Sans lui,
c'est la mort assurée.
D'ailleurs,
cette science fait sa renommée,
mais aussi son prix.
Pour chaque passager,
il a empoché 500 euros,
soit cinq fois
le salaire moyen d'un Libyen.
Pour Élie et Émile,
la somme est énorme,
mais c'est l'assurance de ne jamais
tomber sur une patrouille de police.
Quand on vous arrête,
ce n'est pas facile.
Parfois, il faut payer,
parfois, on vous met en prison.
Vous avez peur
qu'on vous attrape ?
Oui, bien sûr.
Ce n'est pas facile, la torture.
Il leur a fallu huit heures pour
parcourir les 150 kilomètres de désert
entre Mourzouq et Sebha.
La première étape de leur voyage.
Ici, ils vont récupérer
un autre candidat à l'Europe.
C'est un ami,
un Camerounais comme eux.
Sebha marque la limite
du territoire de Pascal.
Maintenant, c'est une autre
filière qui les prend en main.
Mais tout ne va pas
se passer comme prévu.
La ville de Sebha
n'est pas totalement pacifiée.
Elle est en proie
à de violents combats entre milices.
Le passeur qui devait
les récupérer n'est pas là.
Élie angoisse.
Ça lui rappelle les galères
de son premier voyage vers la Libye.
On attend, il y a eu
des moments quand on est arrivés,
on a attendu le passeur pour la Libye
pendant près d'un mois et demi,
six semaines,
donc, on attend.
Émile est effondré.
Le propriétaire des lieux
les installe dans son garage.
Pendant ce temps,
Joseph, l'ami qui part avec eux
en Europe, vient d'arriver en taxi.
Bonjour.
- Comment ça va ?
Ça va très bien.
Joseph est maçon lui aussi.
Il s'est installé
à Sebha il y a trois ans.
Aujourd'hui,
il tente ce voyage de l'impossible
à cause des combats meurtriers
qui ravagent la ville de Sebha.
J'ai dit aux amis,
voilà les amis, l'occasion se présente
pour moi de partir.
Le pays est
dans l'insécurité.
Le pays est en mouvement.
Chaque jour, des troubles,
des coups de feu par-ci, par-là,
c'est mieux de sauver sa tête
et sa vie, donc le mieux serait de bouger
parce que les choses
empirent de jour en jour.
Alors Ivan,
vous étiez où, là ?
Depuis le matin,
personne n'a mangé.
Du pain, du Pepsi.
Avant de repartir, un des hommes
de Pascal est allé acheter de quoi dîner.
Il assure aux clandestins
qu'ils reprendront la route sans faute
demain matin.
Malgré le retard,
tout semble bien organisé.
La nuit n'a pas calmé les combats.
Bien au contraire,
ils redoublent d'intensité.
Pour ne rien arranger,
le thermomètre a plongé.
Il flirte avec les zéros degrés.
Les clandestins ont
un chauffage et quelques couvertures.
Quelques heures plus tard,
c'est la panne d'électricité.
Il fait tellement froid.
Le lendemain matin,
les Camerounais sont désemparés.
Toujours pas de trace
du passeur et Élie commence à douter
sérieusement de sa filière.
Je ne sais
vraiment pas ce qui se passe.
Je pense que le passeur,
il n'a jamais existé, ce passeur
dont on nous a tant parlé.
Continuer le voyage seul
est bien trop dangereux.
Ils n'ont pas
d'autre choix que d'attendre.
Le propriétaire
des lieux accepte de les héberger,
mais à une condition.
Il veut qu'ils construisent un mur pour un
salaire non négociable, 20 euros chacun.
Émile ne l'entend pas de cette oreille.
Ce salaire
de misère, il n'en veut pas.
Pour lui,
c'est de l'esclavage.
C'est fini le travail
avec les Libyens, je ne travaille plus.
Tu ne vas pas
travailler là ?
Non.
- C'est vrai ?
Oui.
- Pourquoi Émile ?
Ils nous ont assez
maltraités comme ça.
Je lui demande de faire semblant,
même s'il ne veut pas travailler,
qu'il fasse semblant.
C'est un petit travail
par rapport à ce qu'on a déjà enduré ici.
On nous a bouffé
des milliers de dinars ici.
Tu travailles dans un chantier pendant
deux mois, après on te sort la kalach,
on te demande de foutre le camp.
Donc, qu'il essaye
de faire semblant.
À contrecœur,
il se met au travail.
À cet instant, le moral
d'Émile, Élie et Joseph est au plus bas.
Comment continuer
le voyage sans passeur ?
Le défi qui les attend est énorme.
À l'autre bout de la planète,
un nouveau jour se lève sur Kaboul,
en Afghanistan.
Kaboul, trois millions d'habitants,
pour la plupart des paysans déplacés
épuisés par
30 ans de guerre.
Parmi eux, deux cousins,
candidats au voyage en Europe.
Javid, en blanc,
Rohani, en gris.
Comme eux,
10 000 jeunes Afghans tentent leur chance
en Europe, chaque année.
En Asie, ce sont les plus
nombreux à émigrer vers Paris ou Londres.
Javid et son cousin Rohani
sont obligés de quitter l'Afghanistan.
Ils nous racontent que dans leur région,
ce sont les talibans qui font la loi.
Et pour s'être opposés
à une de leurs décisions,
leur tête a été mise à prix.
Je veux aller en Europe.
Ici, je suis en danger.
J'ai des problèmes
dans ma province avec les talibans
et je ne peux plus y retourner.
Alors,
je me cache ici à Kaboul.
J'ai peur car
les talibans peuvent m'atteindre.
Même ici, en pleine ville.
Fils de paysans aisés,
Javid et Rohani auraient les moyens
de se payer
un billet d'avion pour Paris.
Mais pour un Afghan,
obtenir un visa européen
est quasiment impossible.
Leur seule option,
fuir le pays clandestinement.
Ce matin, ils ont rendez-vous
avec le chef de la filière des passeurs.
D'autres futurs
clandestins sont aussi présents.
Moi, je vais vous amener
sur une route plutôt tranquille.
Contrairement aux autres passeurs.
Je fournis le pain,
la nourriture et les vêtements.
Vous irez de passeurs
en passeurs tout au long du parcours.
Je resterai
en contact avec eux.
Ils vous amèneront sains
et saufs en Grèce, sans problème.
Contrairement à l'Afrique,
les passeurs afghans organisent tout,
du départ jusqu'à l'arrivée,
comme une agence de voyages.
Une fois l'argent empoché,
ils ont une obligation de résultat,
sauf sur deux points.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe
si on se fait voler ou kidnapper ?
Si vous mourez ou si vous tombez malade,
moi, je ne suis pas responsable.
Bon, pour le voyage,
vous allez me payer 7 000 dollars.
Allez, mon frère,
un bon geste, fais-le-nous à 6005.
OK, 6005.
Mais si en chemin,
vous prenez un autre passeur,
je vous préviens,
je ne rembourse pas.
Même avec cette ristourne,
6 500 dollars est une somme considérable
quand on sait que le salaire moyen
à Kaboul ne dépasse pas 100 euros.
La plupart
des clandestins empruntent pour partir.
Les deux cousins ont de la chance.
Leurs familles paient
une partie du trajet.
Mais ça ne suffit pas.
Javid est obligé de vendre sa voiture.
Et elle vaut
combien sur le marché ?
Elle est cotée 4 500 dollars, je crois.
L'affaire est conclue.
Avec cette vente,
les deux cousins vont payer
les 2 000 dollars d'acompte
réclamés par le passeur.
Le reste de l'argent sera versé
par leur famille au fur et à mesure
de leur avancée vers l'Europe.
Une sécurité indispensable pour éviter
de se faire arnaquer par la filière.
Avant de quitter Kaboul,
leur dernier plaisir est
de passer chez leur barbier.
Les Afghans aiment porter beau,
quelles que soient les circonstances.
Tous les deux
sont célibataires.
À part leur famille,
rien ne les retient à Kaboul,
une ville
qu'ils espèrent ne jamais revoir.
Voilà notre capitale.
Je ne reviendrai pas.
Là-bas,
à Paris, c'est propre.
Il n'y a pas de poussière.
Ici, on ne voit même pas un arbre.
C'est sûr,
Kaboul ne va pas nous manquer.
Je ne sais pas comment
va se passer notre voyage.
Il y aura
des chemins dangereux, de la marche,
on va traverser des forêts,
des montagnes, ça va être très difficile.
Le lendemain matin,
la grande migration vers Paris commence.
Comme l'a promis
le passeur, tout est bien organisé.
Un minibus confortable a été affrété.
À l'intérieur,
30 hommes qui passent pour des touristes.
Le voyage démarre
de façon plutôt agréable.
Mais tout cela n'est qu'illusion.
Leur aventure va se compliquer.
Ils vont parcourir
à pied, en voiture et en bateau,
7 000 kilomètres à travers le Pakistan,
l'Iran, la Turquie et enfin la Grèce.
Sur la route,
ils croisent deux blindés américains.
Dernière image de la guerre
et de ses cauchemars pour Javid et Rohani.
Les Américains
sont sales et méchants.
Ils bloquent les routes
en prétextant qu'il y a une bombe,
mais en réalité, il n'y en a pas.
Tout ce
qu'ils font, c'est nous gêner.
Trois heures plus tard,
une file de plusieurs kilomètres
de camions annonce
la frontière avec le Pakistan.
Tous attendent
de passer le contrôle.
L'endroit est sulfureux
et particulièrement surveillé.
C'est le point
de passage de tous les trafics.
Un nid d'espions.
Ici se croisent
les services secrets pakistanais, afghans
et même la CIA, à la recherche
de djihadistes et de talibans.
Javid et Rohani passent
la frontière à pied.
Nous les filmons discrètement.
Ce sera la seule frontière
qu'ils franchiront sans stress.
Il n'y a pas besoin de passeport
pour les Afghans se rendant au Pakistan.
En trois jours,
le petit groupe de clandestins avale
près d'un millier de kilomètres
en bus pour arriver jusqu'à Lahore.
Dernière étape, avant d'attaquer
les terribles montagnes iraniennes.
Même bien organisés, ces voyages
illégaux ne se font jamais d'une traite.
Parfois,
il faut attendre des jours ou des mois,
dans une sombre cage sans confort.
Cette fois-ci,
ce n'est pas le cas.
À Lahore,
le passeur pakistanais
les a planqués en ville.
À l'intérieur,
la communauté s'organise.
Chacun a une fonction bien précise.
Les tâches ménagères
ne les empêchent pas de rêver.
Ils ont tous une vision
très poétique de la France.
À Paris,
ils aspergent la ville de parfum.
C'est ce qu'on m'a dit.
Il faut fermer les yeux.
Si tu regardes en l'air,
tu en prends plein la tête.
Au début,
ça va être compliqué là-bas à Paris.
Oui, c'est toujours
compliqué quand on change de culture.
Et surtout, ça va être vraiment
compliqué d'apprendre l'égalité.
Ils rigolent,
mais il y a une chose qui les terrorise.
La traversée de l'Iran à pied.
Faouad était routier.
Ses problèmes ont commencé
le jour où sa société a travaillé
pour les Américains.
Considéré
comme un traître par les talibans,
il a décidé
de fuir en Europe.
Faouad a déjà tenté
le voyage, mais il a échoué.
Arrêté en Iran,
il a été expulsé.
Il est donc le seul à savoir
ce qui les attend dans les montagnes.
Faouad, dis-moi, toi qui es déjà allé
en Iran, la route est si difficile ?
Oui, c'est très dur.
Combien de chance
on a d'arriver là-bas ?
Cinq pourcent
de chance, pas plus.
Tu ne peux pas savoir
à quel point c'est difficile.
Ça me fait rire
quand je vous vois aussi optimistes.
Tu crois vraiment
que ça va être une promenade de santé ?
C'est vraiment ce que tu crois ?
Le voyage organisé continue.
Après l'appartement,
le passeur leur a acheté
des billets de train
pour la frontière iranienne.
Javid et Faouad ressemble davantage
à des touristes qu'à des clandestins.
Dans le groupe,
certains ne fuient pas les talibans,
mais les vendettas
qui font des ravages dans le pays.
Le jeune Lukman a rejoint
le groupe à Lahore.
Une partie
de sa famille a été décimée,
dont son propre père.
Tout ça,
pour quelques hectares de terrain.
Pour nous,
le voyage s'arrête à la frontière.
Entrer en Iran
clandestinement pour des journalistes,
c'est prendre le risque
d'être pris pour des espions.
Une accusation très grave
qui mène tout droit en prison.
Nous laissons à Lukman
et ses amis une petite caméra.
Ce sont eux qui vont filmer
cette partie-là du périple.
À partir de cet instant,
le voyage prend une autre tournure.
Le pickup a remplacé
le minibus, mais l'ambiance reste légère.
Je meurs,
on est 30 assis dans ce pickup.
et il y en a trois
assis sur ma jambe.
Trente personnes, 36 même.
Tassés dans ce pickup,
ils n'ont pas encore conscience
de ce qui les attend.
Cette épopée,
ils l'ont filmé de bout en bout à travers
les montagnes
du Baloutchistan et ses dizaines de cols
à plus de 3000 mètres,
et surtout l'impitoyable désert de Makran.
Deux mille kilomètres
à travers l'Iran pour rejoindre Ourmia
à la frontière turque.
Tout cela en évitant soigneusement
les villages et les patrouilles de police.
Ça va Raiber ?
- Oui, ça va.
On commence juste le voyage.
Que Dieu nous protège.
On est nombreux ici.
On est quand même
plus de 100.
160, exactement.
Ce n'est pas par hasard
s'il y a autant de clandestins.
Pour rentabiliser le voyage,
plusieurs réseaux se regroupent.
Comme ça,
ils mutualisent la nourriture
et les planques pour dormir.
On doit escalader cette montagne.
Vous avez vu
combien on est ?
Cette première ascension
leur donne vite une idée de l'effort
à fournir
dans les prochains jours.
Allez, les gars là,
on avance, on avance !
Je suis mort de fatigue !
Mort de fatigue !
Ça fait
cinq heures qu'on marche.
Allez, dépêche-toi avance !
On va être en retard.
Javid aperçoit le sommet.
Il croit dur comme fer
que de l'autre côté, c'est enfin l'Iran.
Pour tous les migrants,
le choc va être brutal.
Il reste combien
de montagnes à traverser ?
Tout ça.
Tout ça ?!
Faouad, on est encore
au Pakistan ou déjà en Iran ?
Au Pakistan.
En descendant là-bas,
c'est toujours le Pakistan ?
Jusqu'à là-bas,
c'est le Pakistan.
Oui,
je t'assure, c'est là-bas.
Et après, c'est l'Iran ?
Oui.
Après deux jours de marche
harassante, les voici enfin en Iran.
Rien n'indique la frontière,
si ce n'est la plaque de ce vieux camion.
C'est le ravitaillement.
À court de vivres,
les Afghans sont rassurés.
Mais la surprise est amère.
Contrairement
à ce qu'avait promis leur passeur,
tout est payant
et les prix sont exorbitants.
Les 160 clandestins
n'ont pas le choix.
Ce racket ne sera pas
le dernier du voyage.
Le groupe de clandestins
passe à la latitude de Bandar Abbas,
tout près
du golfe Persique.
Mais ils ne verront jamais la mer.
Ils ne traversent
que des gorges encaissées,
chauffées à blanc
par le soleil, un four à ciel ouvert.
Les jours les plus torrides,
la température peut atteindre 47 degrés.
Lukman, le plus jeune
des Afghans, commence à regretter
d'avoir quitté son pays.
C'est insoutenable,
ce soleil nous tue.
Et on va continuer
comme ça jour et nuit.
Au moins
18 heures sans s'arrêter.
Pas le temps
de manger, boire ou même d'uriner.
C'est vraiment
une très longue marche
Il n'est pas
le seul à se plaindre.
Un migrant pakistanais
est aussi très en colère
contre les passeurs.
Comment se passe le voyage ?
C'est tout pourri,
enf***** de passeurs.
Ils nous avaient assurés qu'on marcherait
au maximum pendant une heure.
Mais là, ça fait 8 heures
qu'on crapahute et malheureusement,
ce n'est toujours pas fini.
Les passeurs,
vous ne les verrez jamais.
Ils ne se laissent pas filmer,
ils ouvrent la marche d'un pas militaire.
Et tant pis
pour les traînards comme Javid et Faouad.
Pourtant, s'éloigner
du groupe, c'est aussi risquer sa vie.
Il faut se dépêcher,
il faut rester au milieu du groupe.
En plus,
la nuit approche et ce n'est pas bon.
Il y a des voleurs.
Je pense qu'il y en a.
Ils ont l'habitude de voler l'argent,
les sacs,
et même les chaussures.
Javid, Faouad et Lukman
ont atteint un point de non-retour.
Perdus au milieu de nulle part,
il leur est impossible
de faire machine arrière.
Maintenant,
il faut qu'ils regardent droit devant,
vers la frontière turque
à plus de 1500 kilomètres.
En Libye, le moral est
au plus bas pour les trois Camerounais.
Le passeur n'est toujours pas là
et le mur qu'ils construisent pour payer
leur séjour est bientôt terminé.
Le propriétaire risque
de les mettre à la porte.
Alors Joseph va prendre
leur destin en main.
Oui, bonjour.
Comment se passe la matinée ?
Tu es dans ton lieu de service ?
Joseph a des connexions.
Plusieurs amis à lui
ont déjà organisé des traversées.
Après des dizaines
de coups de téléphone
et des heures de prières.
Le miracle arrive enfin.
Joseph a trouvé
un nouveau passeur.
L'homme promet de les emmener
sans encombre jusqu'à la mer.
Donc,
le départ, c'est ce soir ?
Encore une fois,
ils refont valise commune.
Et avant de partir,
le propriétaire des lieux
leur verse
leur salaire, 160 dinars libyens,
soit les 20 euros
promis pour chacun d'eux.
120, 140, 150,
155, 160.
Mais il y a un problème.
Les nouveaux passeurs refusent
d'être suivis par des journalistes.
Ils ne peuvent pas courir
le risque de nous mélanger à vous
donc, ils ont décidé
qu'on prenne notre véhicule.
Et vous, vous allez trouver
votre moyen de transport,
un moyen
pour vous retrouver à Tripoli.
Nous,
on partira à trois de notre côté.
Nous filons donc par
la route principale les attendre à Tripoli
la capitale libyenne,
700 kilomètres plus au nord.
Eux,
vont prendre un autre chemin.
Une fois de plus,
ils passent par le désert
et des routes secondaires
dans de vieux pickups, mais aussi à pied.
Puis tout dérape.
Les passeurs
se comportent en tortionnaires.
La souffrance
des trois Camerounais va durer six jours
au lieu des deux prévus.
Nous avons suivi
leur calvaire par téléphone.
Combien de changements de passeurs
et d'étapes vous avez fait depuis Sebha ?
Vous avez changé
cinq fois de passeur ?
Donc là, vous êtes
à combien de kilomètres de Tripoli ?
Donc, vous avez
à peine fait 100 km ?
Oui.
Les passeurs les maltraitent.
Et quand ils osent se plaindre,
Vous n'avez plus rien, là ?
Ils vous ont volé ça ?
L'argent que
vous avez gagné à Sebha ?
Mais ils l'ont trouvé où ?
Une semaine plus tard,
nous les retrouvons donc à Tripoli.
Ils ont été recueillis
par la communauté camerounaise.
Ils ont perdu du poids.
On dirait des fantômes.
Voici leur récit.
On est fatigués.
C'était très dur ?
- Ouais, très dur.
On n'imaginait pas
ça comme ça, dans tous les cas.
On se voyait en route
peut-être maximum pour deux jours,
peut-être trois jours,
mais pas jusqu'à six jours.
Avec ce qu'on a enduré
comme difficultés, comme torture.
Parce que là,
c'était vraiment de la torture.
Un enfer, plus que l'enfer.
Parce que
je n'ai jamais vu depuis ma naissance,
je n'ai jamais vu
des choses aussi horribles.
Il y a des gens qui pleurent,
des gaillards,
des papas qui pleurent à chaudes larmes.
Puis quand tu te mets
à pleurer, ils passent avec le bâton,
au-dessus de la couverture,
ils tapent fort, un gros bâton comme ça.
Ils nous traitent d'esclaves,
ils disent, "écoute, ferme-là esclave !"
À un moment donné,
nous sommes arrivés.
Il nous a parqués quelque part,
Pas de nourriture, pas d'eau.
Je sors ma Bible
pour prier au calme.
Il me voit avec la Bible.
Il demande "qu'est-ce que
tu es en train de faire esclave ?"
Il vient, me tabasse,
il arrache ma Bible, il la jette.
Les moins résistants sont abandonnés
purement et simplement dans le désert.
C'est ce qui est arrivé
à ces migrants qui ont trouvé la mort
à la frontière
entre la Libye et l'Algérie.
Pour Émile,
ce voyage restera gravé
à jamais dans sa mémoire.
Il a aidé à marcher,
puis porté un homme à bout de force
sur près
de deux kilomètres.
Mais à un moment donné,
il ne pouvait même plus parler.
Il me disait
seulement "aide-moi".
Le gars est tombé, je suis en train
de soulever le gars, il pèse plus que moi.
Je mets la main
sur le cou du gars, ça ne bat plus.
sur le cœur, ça ne bat plus.
Je dis à l'Arabe
que le gars est mort,
il me dit,
"s'il est mort, tire le au sol".
J'ai dit
"non, je ne peux pas le tirer comme ça".
C'est quand même
un mort, on doit le respecter.
Il m'a dit "si tu ne veux pas le tirer",
il m'a mis le fusil ici, sur la tête.
Je lui ai dit
que je ne peux pas.
Il a commencé à me taper
avec le fusil, il me crachait dessus.
Ils ont porté
le gars, ils l'ont mis là-bas.
Je ne sais pas
comment ils ont fait avec lui.
Je n'ai aucune idée
de ce qu'ils ont fait de lui.
Mais au bout
de toutes ces souffrances, une récompense.
Voir enfin la Méditerranée.
Leur dernier défi est devant eux.
De l'autre côté, il y a l'Europe.
Cette mer,
il faut maintenant la traverser.
Cela fait près de trois ans
qu'ils ont laissé le Cameroun
derrière eux.
Chacun se prend à rêver.
Joseph pense
qu'il a de l'or dans les mains.
Il est sûr que son talent
fera merveille en France.
Les gens disent
que je suis un génie dans la décoration.
Je peux devenir un artiste
de la décoration, on ne sait jamais.
Malgré ses 19 ans,
Émile a des rêves plus sages.
Mon rêve, c'est de réussir à avoir
une maison, des enfants, une femme.
Je sais qu'en Europe,
c'est la galère pour les sans papiers.
Et je sais aussi qu'il y a
ceux qui sont arrivés sans papiers
et aujourd'hui, ils ont les papiers,
donc, pourquoi pas moi ?
Pour Élie,
ce voyage est une revanche.
C'est avant tout
pour faire ses preuves qu'il l'a entamé.
Dans ma famille, il y en a
beaucoup qui n'ont pas cru en moi.
J'ai tout fait pour
qu'ils sachent que peut-être ma réussite,
c'était de l'autre côté
de la Méditerranée.
Je sais que je suis fort
physiquement, fort mentalement.
En Europe,
il y a beaucoup d'ouvertures,
parce que je me dis que la chance
que je n'ai pas pu avoir en Afrique,
au Cameroun plus précisément,
peut-être que
de l'autre côté, je pourrais l'avoir.
Pour eux,
c'est l'ultime étape avant Paris.
Pourtant, leurs galères
sont loin d'être terminées.
Traverser la Méditerranée
est hors de prix,
même sur
un bateau de fortune.
Or, ils sont ruinés.
Les passeurs
leur ont pris toutes leurs économies.
Ils vont devoir travailler
sur des chantiers à Zouara.
Nous sommes en janvier,
nous les retrouverons dans cinq mois.
C'est du port
de Zouara, à 100 kilomètres de Tripoli,
que partent la majorité
des bateaux d'illégaux.
Été comme hiver,
la ville est envahie de clandestins.
Tous ne survivront pas à cette traversée
vers l'île italienne de Lampedusa.
250 kilomètres de mer
qui s'effectuent sur des bateaux de pêche
comme celui-ci.
Prévus pour quelques marins,
les passeurs y entassent
des centaines d'immigrés
afin de faire
un maximum de profit.
Toutes les semaines, les militaires
ramassent sur les plages de Zouara,
les corps des suppliciés
rejetés par la mer.
Cinq mois plus tard,
Émile, Joseph et Élie
ont gagné assez d'argent
pour traverser la Méditerranée.
Ils nous ont téléphoné.
Nous les retrouvons
sur leur dernier chantier.
On est presque au bout,
donc, on est bien, on essaye de travailler
au maximum
car il ne faut pas juste payer
le transport
pour Lampedusa,
il faut aussi arriver
avec un peu d'argent de poche.
À Zouara, rien de plus facile
que de rencontrer des passeurs.
Il y en a à tous les carrefours.
Et ce sont souvent
eux qui démarchent les clandestins.
Joseph et Élie ont
rendez-vous avec l'un d'entre eux.
Ils vont négocier
leur passage, mais aussi le nôtre.
Nous filmons
la rencontre en caméra cachée.
Le passeur, c'est cet homme de dos,
à la casquette et au téléphone rose.
J'ai des amis
qui veulent traverser.
Ils ont appelé hier.
Ils cherchent
une bonne filière pour passer.
Ouais, ils sont cinq.
Les trois Camerounais, plus nous.
Combien
vous pouvez mettre ?
600, 800 euros ?
OK, je réfléchis.
Donne-moi ton numéro.
Après plusieurs jours de négociations,
ils finissent par s'entendre sur un prix.
Ce sera 900 euros par journaliste
et 600 euros pour chacun des Camerounais.
Maintenant,
on déterre nos économies.
Le voyage, c'est demain.
Cet argent,
c'est la sueur de mon front.
J'ai bien travaillé,
je le mérite très bien.
Je mérite plus que ça.
On a travaillé, on ne nous a pas tout payé
avec la souffrance qu'on a enduré ici.
Ça nous réconforte
quand même, parce que ça
paye le transport jusqu'à l'Italie.
Je ne suis jamais monté
sur un bateau, c'est la première fois.
Tu n'as pas trop peur ?
Si, j'ai peur.
Mais pas trop.
La hantise
du naufrage est dans toutes les têtes.
Surtout qu'ils ne savent pas
sur quelle embarcation ils vont voyager.
Certaines traversées se font
sur des coquilles de noix comme celle-là.
Début octobre,
trois bateaux ont sombré,
dont un,
avec 500 personnes à bord.
En deux ans, 3 600 clandestins
auraient trouvé la mort en mer.
Le risque est immense,
mais la promesse d'une vie meilleure
en Europe est plus forte que tout.
Deux jours plus tard,
le moment tant attendu est arrivé.
Ils sont convoqués sans bagages
sur une plage au nord de Zouara.
Émile,
comme les autres, retient son souffle.
Le bruit pourrait les signaler
aux policiers qui patrouillent.
Après une heure
d'attente, le signal est donné.
Les dizaines de migrants prennent d'assaut
les petites embarcations des passeurs.
Quelques minutes plus tard,
ils les pressent de grimper à bord
d'un bateau
beaucoup plus gros.
Les migrants ne voient rien,
ne savent pas combien ils sont.
Une seule certitude,
maintenant, ils sont livrés à eux-mêmes.
Sur le pont,
cette femme enceinte se sent déjà mal
et son voyage
n'a pas commencé.
À 5 heures du matin,
l'aube leur permet
de découvrir l'embarcation
et leurs compagnons d'infortune.
Au total, ils sont 260.
Parmi eux, des Érythréens,
des Somaliens, des Libyens.
À bord, devant le danger,
les différences religieuses s'effacent.
Chacun s'en remet à son Dieu.
Joseph cherche Élie et Émile.
Ils ont été séparés
à l'embarquement.
Je suis en train de chercher
un passage, pour qu'on puisse trouver
mes deux frères en bas.
Mais la cale avant est inaccessible.
Il n'y a pas
possibilité d'y pénétrer.
Il y a trop de monde,
l'endroit est bouché, complètement bouché.
Nous parvenons néanmoins
à descendre par la trappe arrière,
le pire endroit du bateau.
Une centaine de clandestins
s'y entassent les uns sur les autres.
Il règne
une odeur insoutenable
et la chaleur est suffocante.
Il n'y a aucun souffle d'air.
Le bruit assourdissant
du moteur casse les têtes.
Mais je n'ai pas le choix.
Une heure après le départ,
les passeurs ont organisé
un petit-déjeuner frugal.
Une distribution
d'eau, de pain et de fromage.
Les visages se dérident.
Ils ne le savent pas encore,
mais ce sera leur seul repas
pendant la traversée.
Pas sûr que les damnés
de la cale, eux, aient le cœur à manger.
De Tripoli à Lampedusa,
moi, j'ai payé 1 400 dollars par personne.
Pour nous, trois.
Pour moi,
ma femme et la petite Aïcha.
Les prix du trajet
sont peut-être différents,
mais tous se sont ruinés
pour la même raison.
On le sait que c'est risqué.
Mais si on est tous là,
c'est pour enfin avoir quelque chose
à manger
dans nos assiettes.
Pour les passeurs,
ce trafic est très rentable.
D'après nos estimations,
les 260 migrants ont rapporté à la filière
près de 200 000 euros.
Et pourtant, à bord,
pas un seul gilet de sauvetage
ni aucune fusée
de détresse en cas de naufrage.
Pour s'orienter,
le capitaine ne possède
que le strict minimum,
une boussole et un GPS grand public.
On tient le bon cap
grâce à ce petit GPS et cette boussole.
Pour le moment, tout va bien.
Lampedusa est encore loin.
Il leur reste
12 heures de navigation,
et le pire est encore à venir.
Dépêche-toi,
tu es toujours le dernier.
De leur côté, les Afghans,
Javid, Faouad,
Rohani et Lukman
ont bien avancé en Iran.
Ils ont parcouru 3 500 kilomètres.
Ils se trouvent maintenant
dans la région iranienne de Fars,
au centre du pays.
Ils sont exténués.
Les passeurs impitoyables
imposent une cadence infernale.
Plus vite
le groupe arrive à destination,
plus vite
ils pourront aller en chercher un autre.
Au septième jour
de marche, Lukman commence à craquer.
On a franchi au moins 50,
ou 60 montagnes, mais ça continue.
À ce stade de la marche,
les muscles deviennent douloureux,
les articulations souffrent.
Rohani n'en peut plus.
Mes jambes me font très mal.
Cet endroit est très difficile.
D'autant qu'aucun
clandestin n'est réellement équipé
pour une marche aussi longue.
Beaucoup sont en chaussures de ville
ou en baskets de mauvaise qualité.
Javid, lui,
souffre depuis plusieurs heures.
Ses chaussures pakistanaises
se sont désintégrées sur les rochers.
Ça, ce sont
les chaussures made in Pakistan.
Ses pieds ne sont pas
en meilleur état.
On n'a pas pu
se laver, on est très sales.
Regarde un peu
mes chaussettes.
Et tu as vu
le pied de Faouad?
Tu as vu son ampoule ?
Ces épreuves n'empêchent pas
la solidarité entre marcheurs clandestins.
Depuis une heure, ce vieil homme
souffre le martyre à chaque pas.
Et c'est Javid
qui va le soigner.
Tu es tombé ?
Oui.
Ça te fait mal ?
Oui,
ça me fait très mal.
Prévoyant, Javid a emporté
une petite trousse de secours.
Sers le bandage davantage.
Ce sera plus efficace.
Tu peux marcher, Baba ?
Oui.
Que quelqu'un reste à ses côtés.
Après la fatigue,
l'autre ennemi, c'est la déshydratation.
On a soif, tellement soif.
Chacun porte
une bouteille, mais quand elle est vide,
les Afghans dépendent
des trous d'eau croisés
au hasard de la marche.
La plupart du temps,
c'est une eau sale,
mais ils n'hésitent pas
à y plonger leur bouteille,
au risque
de tomber malade.
Tu as soif ?
Oui, j'ai très soif,
mais il n'y a pas d'eau.
Enfin si,
il y en a, mais elle est sale
et on a besoin de boire.
Elle a quel goût ?
Elle est vraiment infecte.
Javid a trouvé une astuce
peut-être pas très efficace, mais simple.
Il filtre l'eau
avec son foulard.
Au dixième jour de marche,
la colonne des 160 clandestins
s'étire et finit
par se disloquer.
Certains sont à la traîne,
épuisés par la fatigue,
ils n'arrivent
même plus à rattraper le groupe.
Javid et ses camarades s'écroulent.
On est fatigués,
on est trop fatigués.
Des gens sont restés loin derrière.
Oui,
ils sont nombreux à la traîne.
Un Pakistanais est salement amoché.
S'il reste là,
tu crois qu'il va mourir ?
Bien sûr qu'il va mourir.
Et toi, Faouad ?
Tu te caches derrière les branches ?
Comment tu te sens ?
Je ne me sens pas bien.
À partir de Chiraz, la frontière turque
est encore à 1 000 kilomètres.
Mais une surprise les attend.
Certaines portions
du trajet vont se faire en voiture.
30 kilomètres ici,
20 kilomètres là de gagnés,
puis, retour à l'effort.
Je ne comprends pas.
Pourquoi
ils nous ont fait descendre du camion ?
Ils nous font passer par ailleurs.
Peut-être que la route est bloquée.
Depuis qu'ils sont en Iran,
ils alternent
les bivouacs en pleine montagne,
loin des repas
promis par les passeurs.
Ne mange surtout pas ce pain,
il est moisi,tu vas être malade.
Et les planques
pas forcément plus confortables.
Il fait une chaleur. C'est horrible.
Ils nous ont forcés
à sortir et à rester dehors.
Il fait une chaleur de dingue.
Qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire maintenant ?
Il fait tellement chaud, ça me tue.
Je n'ai rien
à boire avec ce gâteau.
Pas d'eau.
Ça reste collé dans ma gorge.
C'est pas terrible.
Ces caches ont
un avantage, elles ont l'électricité,
ce qui leur permet
de recharger leur téléphone.
Et c'est loin d'être un luxe.
Bizarrement, les guides
abandonnent parfois les clandestins
en leur indiquant
juste la direction à suivre.
Quand le groupe se perd,
c'est la panique.
Comme ce jour-là, Javid,
à bout de nerfs, appelle le passeur.
Envoyez-nous quelqu'un !
Si personne ne vient,
je vous dénonce à la police.
Va te faire voir.
Il a dit qu'il nous envoyait
quelqu'un dans 20 minutes.
C'est ce qu'il vient de me dire.
Il dit ça depuis des heures.
Les télécoms iraniens
sont plutôt performants.
Il y a du réseau
dans toutes les montagnes.
Passé Téhéran,
la capitale iranienne,
ils filent droit vers la Turquie,
entassés dans une vieille Peugeot.
Certains sont même
enfermés dans le coffre.
Nous sommes à la mi-mai.
Ils ont quitté
l'Afghanistan il y a un mois
et ils atteignent
maintenant les montagnes du Kurdistan
qui les séparent de la Turquie.
Nous les retrouvons
à cette étape et reprenons
le fil du tournage.
Ici, les paysages tranchent
avec les montagnes pelées
du centre de l'Iran.
Place aux alpages
et au climat frais.
Les passeurs ont prévu
des vêtements chauds pour les Afghans.
Les gâteaux ne sont plus moisis.
Ils retrouvent visage humain.
Ce jour-là, tous se font
aussi chics que possible.
Séance photo improvisée.
Le passeur local a préparé
des demandes d'asile turques
avec de faux noms.
Il n'y a plus qu'à coller les photos.
Regarde, c'est drôle,
maintenant, je m'appelle Hamid Ahmadzai.
S'il y a des contrôles
de police, grâce à ces papiers,
on va pouvoir rejoindre
Istanbul tranquillement.
Leur traversée
est prévue dans dix jours.
Là-bas, c'est la montagne
où on doit passer la frontière.
Derrière la chaîne du Kurdistan,
c'est la Turquie, la porte de l'Europe.
Mais pour l'atteindre,
ils vont devoir affronter le froid
et la neige.
Troisième heure de souffrance
pour les 260 clandestins africains.
Au fond de la cale,
Émile ne se sent pas bien.
Elie, de son côté,
réussit à s'extraire de cet enfer.
Joseph lui a fait
une petite place à côté de lui.
J'ai le cœur et le ventre
qui bourdonnent, j'ai le cœur qui va
de haut en bas.
Ça me donne l'envie
de vomir, mais je n'ai pas encore vomi.
Tout le monde
là-bas vomit depuis hier.
Trois fois, deux fois,
moi je n'ai pas encore vomi.
Je n'ai même pas mangé,
je n'arrive à rien avaler.
Joseph vérifie que son agenda
très spécial n'a pas été effacé.
Il a mis les pieds dans l'eau
avant de monter sur le bateau.
Ce sont les numéros
de téléphone que j'ai marqués là,
parce que les Libyens,
les passeurs prennent tous les téléphones
et les SIM Cards, je l'ai pressenti.
J'ai écrit tous les numéros là.
Le capitaine vient d'annoncer
que l'heure libyenne, c'est terminé.
Il vient d'annoncer,
il y a 30 secondes.
Bonne nouvelle ?
- Bonne nouvelle.
D'un seul coup,
tout devient possible.
Mais rares sont les bateaux
qui dépassent les eaux territoriales.
À la cinquième heure de traversée,
le son assourdissant du moteur se tait.
Une odeur inquiétante
se répand sur le pont.
C'est une pièce
du moteur qui a pris feu.
Ce sont des choses
qui arrivent, c'est la machine.
Ils vont dépanner
et puis on va partir.
Elie reste philosophe.
Contrairement à la femme enceinte.
C'est une sale journée.
Si le bateau prend feu, on va tous mourir.
Tais toi, tais toi !
On va tous mourir, je te dis.
Ça ne sert à rien de paniquer.
Notre vie dépend de lui.
On est obligé de lui faire confiance.
Une demi-heure
plus tard, le moteur repart.
Mais l'incident a marqué les esprits.
Une certaine tension
règne désormais à bord.
Ce jeune Libyen
ne supporte plus les allers
et venues de certains passagers.
Il tente l'intimidation
puis se lève, menaçant.
Au retour, il manque
de blesser la passagère enceinte.
C'est à cause
de ceux qui sont devant.
Ça suffit,
s'ils se mettent debout,
ils vont nous faire chavirer.
À la douxième heure de navigation,
un hélicoptère
de la sécurité civile italienne
les survole.
Un premier signe,
ils vont peut-être pouvoir
tourner le dos
à leur ancienne vie de misère.
Certains étaient fonctionnaires
ou même militaires, des postes privilégiés
dans leur pays,
mais qui leur permettaient
pourtant tout juste de survivre.
Je n'imaginais pas
un instituteur ou un professeur
ou un militaire en train
de gagner sept dollars par mois.
Mais qu'est-ce que
ça représente sept dollars ?
Comment
quelqu'un va vivre avec sept dollars ?
Si on donne
sept dollars à un Belge ?
Là où il y a le siège
de l'Union européenne
qui crée toutes les lois
pour bloquer l'immigration.
Pour vivre par mois,
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire
avec sept dollars ?
Prévenue par
la sécurité civile,
la marine italienne intervient.
Immédiatement,
le capitaine du navire lâche la barre.
l'armée prend des photos
et s'il est identifié comme tel,
la sanction est automatique.
20 minutes plus tard,
un bâtiment militaire italien vient
à leur rencontre.
Les migrants s'énervent.
Ils sont restés assis
et comprimés pendant plus de dix heures.
Le Lybien qui jouait du couteau
cherche encore une fois la bagarre.
Combien y a-t-il d'enfants ?
Trois.
Des femmes enceintes ?
Des gilets de sauvetage
au cas où un clandestin tomberait à l'eau
dans la bousculade.
Ne vous inquiétez pas,
il y en aura pour tout le monde.
Il y en aura pour tout le monde !
Asseyez-vous !
Rapproche-toi,
vas-y, envoie la corde.
Le transbordement
des Africains va durer des heures.
Les Camerounais sont
les derniers à monter à bord.
Joseph, Élie et Émile respirent.
Ils ont vaincu la Méditerranée.
Quand ils touchent
enfin le sol de Lampedusa,
21 heures se sont écoulées
depuis leur départ de Libye.
Leur voyage vers Paris
est loin d'être terminé.
Pour atteindre la capitale,
il va falloir qu'ils s'échappent
de l'île de Lampedusa.
Cela fait 20 ans que l'île
toute proche des côtes tunisiennes
et libyennes
est la cible des migrants africains.
Dans le port,
le cimetière des rafiots clandestins
témoigne des arrivées massives.
En 2013,
15 000 personnes auraient cherché
à débarquer à Lampedusa.
Les trois Camerounais sont recueillis
dans ce camp
spécialement construit par l'État italien.
Prévu pour 250 personnes,
il en accueille plus d'un millier.
Et l'été, quand la mer est calme,
l'afflux de migrants est tel
qu'ils sont obligés de dormir dehors.
Logiquement, Emile,
Joseph et Élie devraient y rester
au minimum un an, le temps
que leur demande d'asile soit examinée.
Si elle est rejetée,
ils seront renvoyés au Cameroun.
Mais un événement
imprévu va bousculer leur destin.
Début juillet,
le pape François se rend à Lampedusa
célébrer une messe
à la mémoire des migrants morts en mer.
Avant son arrivée,
une partie du camp est vidée,
pour éviter les débordements.
Les Camerounais
et d'autres clandestins sont évacués
par avion en Sicile.
Dans un autre camp
de rétention, Cara Mineo.
Un ancien lotissement
pour militaires américains de l'OTAN.
Il est, lui aussi, surpeuplé,
4 000 migrants pour 1 500 places.
La caméra n'est pas la bienvenue.
Pour retrouver Élie, Émile et Joseph,
pas d'autre solution
que d'entrer clandestinement de nuit.
Une fois à l'intérieur,
nous sommes accueillis par le chef
de la communauté camerounaise.
Il nous fait visiter
une petite ville avec ses cybercafés,
ses épiceries,
ses lieux de prostitution.
Les migrants sont tous
dans la même galère et pourtant
les nationalités
ne se mélangent pas.
Les tensions sont même
fréquentes entre elles.
Les carabiniers italiens
s'en lavent les mains.
Il n'y a jamais
de gendarmes qui patrouillent ?
Chaque quartier est occupé
par une communauté.
Robert nous emmène
dans la maison où vivent les Camerounais.
À l'intérieur,
l'ambiance semble sympathique.
Il n'y a pas de meubles,
mais il y a de quoi trinquer.
Joseph, Émile
et Élie sont effondrés.
Ils ne partagent pas
l'enthousiasme général.
On m'a envoyé
dans une maison, il est presque minuit,
mais les gens ne dorment pas,
les gens marchent partout.
La maison,
c'est la boutique, c'est le bar.
C'est la maison
où on dort, que voulez-vous ?
Joseph est révolté.
Il s'attendait à un autre accueil.
On ne leur sert
qu'un repas par jour.
Quand quelqu'un doit manger,
est-ce que c'est normal pour un immigré
de manger ceci ?
Si c'est de cette façon
qu'on traite les immigrés ici en Italie,
vraiment, c'est lamentable.
Au Cameroun,
on aime le show.
Quand ils ont faim,
une seule solution.
La boutique de Mama Véronique.
Qu'est-ce que tu fais, ici ?
Je vends, je me débrouille,
pour ne pas chômer,
pour ne pas rester sans rien faire.
Je m'occupe un peu.
Mama Véronique fait
ses courses dans le village d'à côté.
Car tous ont le droit
de sortir du camp dans la journée
avec une obligation, revenir le soir.
Je vais acheter ça, je viens,
je détaille encore petit à petit
pour avoir
au moins un euro par paquet.
Ce sont les Africains qui achètent.
Si je ne fais pas ça,
la vie du camp va m'obliger
à me prostituer.
Comme je ne veux pas
me prostituer, je suis obligée
de faire quelque chose
pour gagner du temps.
Obtenir un titre
de séjour est loin d'être simple.
Mieux vaut venir
d'un pays en guerre ou être persécuté.
Sinon, c'est l'expulsion
et retour à la case départ.
Mais les commissions
d'examens sont débordées
et les réponses arrivent
parfois des mois, voire des années après.
Aucun des Camerounais
ne veut attendre aussi longtemps.
Ils vont filer à l'anglaise.
J'ai pris ma décision, je pars.
Tu comprends ?
- Je pars aussi.
Lui aussi a pris sa décision,
il part, mais cela doit être fait
en toute âme et conscience.
C'est un chemin
de non-retour qu'on va prendre.
Je ne peux pas
rester ici dans la galère.
Le problème, c'est qu'on a engagé
une procédure concernant la résidence.
Je préfère être
sans papiers toute ma vie que de passer
deux ans dans ce camp.
Peut-être que
c'est là que je vais mourir,
me transformer,
et peut-être devenir un criminel.
Je préfère être
dehors dans le noir,
plutôt que
de rester dans ce camp.
Javid, Lukman
et Rohani se reposent à Istanbul
depuis près d'une semaine.
Leur visage est
maintenant détendu.
Pourtant,
ils sont arrivés en piteux état.
Le passage entre l'Iran et la Turquie
n'a pas été une partie de plaisir.
Le groupe d'Afghans
a dû batailler avec la pluie,
la neige et le froid.
Leur prochaine destination, la Grèce.
Ils vont la rejoindre
à bord d'un bateau de clandestins.
Avant de risquer leur vie
en mer, ils ouvrent grand leurs yeux
sur Istanbul.
Un choc culturel.
C'est la première fois
que les Afghans voient des femmes
qui ne sont pas
couvertes de la tête aux pieds
et osent montrer
autant leur corps.
Tu as vu ? Les filles sont
habillées super légèrement ici.
Chez nous,
les femmes ne peuvent pas
s'habiller comme ça.
Parce qu'en Afghanistan, on a la charia.
Et si les talibans voyaient
des femmes habillées aussi léger,
il y aurait
des réactions très violentes.
Javid et Rohani
sont avant tout des montagnards,
des paysans
qui n'ont jamais vu la mer.
La traversée
vers les îles grecques a tout
pour les inquiéter.
C'est la première fois que je vois la mer.
Ça a l'air
très profond, c'est terrifiant.
J'ai très peur de l'eau.
Mais demain,
on prend le bateau, pas le choix.
Il n'y a pas d'autres chemins.
Le 22 mai,
ils quittent Istanbul,
cachés dans un minibus
fourni par la filière des passeurs.
Direction Kusadasi,
célèbre station balnéaire
dans l'ouest de la Turquie.
Un mois après
leur départ d'Afghanistan,
ils s'apprêtent
à entrer en Europe.
Mais ce plan
bien huilé va mal tourner.
Alors qu'ils se dirigent à pied
vers le point de rendez-vous
avec le passeur, ils vont
se faire surprendre par la police turque.
Nous les retrouvons
juste après leur débandade.
Au total,
la police a arrêté 50 clandestins.
Ils ne sont plus qu'une dizaine.
On va rester ici jusqu'à ce soir.
Ça ne craint rien.
Le passeur a été arrêté.
Ils sont livrés à eux-mêmes.
Paniqué, Javid appelle
le chef de la filière en Turquie.
Si on trouve un taxi,
on retourne à Istanbul ou à Kusadasi.
Allez, on commence à aller
vers Kusadasi, après il nous rappelle.
À Kusadasi, ils seront pris
en main par un nouveau passeur.
Deux jours plus tard,
c'est la grande traversée.
Comme les Africains,
les Afghans s'apprêtent à prendre la mer.
Cette fois-ci, ce n'est pas
l'Italie qui est visée, mais la Grèce.
Sur la plage,
tout le monde se tait.
Un silence si profond
que l'on entend même les moustiques.
Saleté de moustiques.
Là, on n'est plus très loin
de la frontière grecque par la mer.
La frontière est
au milieu de la grande mer
On va traverser
cette étendue à bord d'un petit bateau.
On est peut-être 35.
On va se retrouver
sur ce petit bateau.
C'est très dangereux.
Le signal est donné.
Ils embarquent
sur un bateau gonflable poussé
par un simple moteur
de 15 chevaux.
Direction l'île grecque
de Samos, dont on aperçoit les lumières
juste à un kilomètre de là.
À bord,
tous évitent de bouger.
L'embarcation est tellement
petite, qu'elle pourrait chavirer
À cause du poids, l'eau s'infiltre,
mais Javid ne s'affole pas.
Sa peur de la mer
n'est plus un problème.
Moi, je n'ai peur
que d'une seule chose, c'est de Dieu.
Soudain, ils se retrouvent pris
dans les phares des garde-côtes grecs.
Logiquement, les policiers
devraient leur venir en aide.
Mais ce soir-là,
ils vont se montrer cruels.
Les garde-côtes prennent leur moteur
et les repoussent dans les eaux turques.
À la dérive,
Ils sont maintenant à la merci
d'une mauvaise vague.
Les policiers nous ont pris
le moteur et l'essence.
Et ils nous ont abandonnés.
Les sales Grecs !
Ils nous ont pourri notre voyage
et en plus
ils nous ont abandonnés.
Sans moteur,
l'embarcation est devenue instable.
Ballottés par les vagues,
les 35 naufragés ont peur.
Le petit pneumatique
dérive au gré des courants.
Résignés,
les clandestins se mettent à fumer.
À l'inverse de tout à l'heure,
ils cherchent à se faire repérer.
Lève le briquet
pour qu'ils nous voient.
A l'aube, l'espoir renaît sous la forme
d'un bateau des garde-côtes turcs.
Il recueille les migrants
pour les ramener à terre.
Montez à bord !
Un par un.
OK, c'est bon,
on fait comme ça.
Ils ont sauvé leurs vies,
mais la partie est loin d'être gagnée.
Le gouvernement turc n'est pas
très tendre avec les clandestins.
Nos trois Afghans,
risquent l'expulsion immédiate.
En Sicile, Élie, Émile
et Joseph ont fui le camp de rétention
sans attendre
leur carte de séjour.
Les conséquences sont graves.
Ils ont perdu leur statut
de réfugiés et sont maintenant considérés
comme clandestins en Europe.
On attend le bus pour aller
au port, pour prendre un ferry cette nuit
qui va nous conduire à Napoli
demain, on essaiera demain matin.
Ils n'ont qu'une idée en tête
rallier le continent et Paris
où ils ont
des contacts et des amis.
Seul problème, ils n'ont même pas
un passeport camerounais en poche.
Et pour acheter un billet
de bateau, le document est obligatoire.
Une sécurité pour éviter
que des clandestins ne quittent l'île.
Mais il y a
une faille dans ce système.
La surprise est énorme.
Le bus monte sur le ferry, et là,
personne ne leur demande de papiers.
Tout à l'heure, on nous a dit
qu'on ne pouvait pas emprunter le bateau
sans passeport.
Et subitement, je me retrouve
dans un bus dans le bateau.
Tu comprends
que c'est surprenant ?
Pour aller jusqu'à Rome,
ils n'ont sur eux que 125 euros.
De l'argent récolté
grâce à un peu de business dans le camp
et aux quelques euros
envoyés par leur famille.
Le rêve français
est enfin à portée de main.
Entre Paris et eux,
il n'y a plus que 1 500 petits kilomètres.
En Turquie,
le voyage vers l'Europe a tourné court
pour les Afghans.
Après leur arrestation
en mer, ils ont été emprisonnés.
Au bout de trois semaines,
Javid et Rohani
ont été renvoyés en Afghanistan.
Seuls deux ont échappé
aux autorités turques.
Le jeune Lukman,
en blanc et Faouad, le chauffeur routier.
Début juillet,
nous les retrouvons à Istanbul.
Faouad et moi,
on s'en est tirés
car on a dit
qu'on avait 16 ans et demi.
Du coup, on a été envoyé
dans un camp pour mineurs.
De là, on s'est échappés
et nous sommes revenus à Istanbul.
Après plusieurs
tentatives ratées de passage en Grèce,
la filière modifie l'itinéraire.
Un changement de cap
qui va coûter 3 500 euros de plus
à leurs familles.
Direction, la Sicile.
Les deux Afghans la rejoignent,
cachés dans un bateau de tourisme.
De là, ils gagnent Rome.
Nous les retrouvons devant le Colisée.
C'est incroyable, j'ai déjà vu
ce monument dans les films.
J'en ai entendu parler
bien sûr, c'est très vieux.
Ça doit dater
d'il y a 1 000 ans au moins.
Rome, c'est ici
que s'arrête le contrat des passeurs.
Lukman et Faouad doivent
se débrouiller maintenant tout seul.
Contrairement aux Africains,
ils ne se sont jamais fait racketter.
Il leur reste quelques économies.
Suffisamment
pour rejoindre Paris.
Deux tickets pour Vintimille.
Le train de 15 heures.
Oui, deux tickets.
Les trois Camerounais
étaient dans cette même gare
deux semaines plus tôt,
mais eux n'avaient plus un sou en poche.
Nous les suivons depuis près
de huit mois, des liens se sont tissés.
Et devant leur détresse,
nous avons choisi de leur venir
en aide en payant
leur billet de train jusqu'à Paris.
Sur le quai, Émile
et ses deux amis sont ébahis
devant tant de modernité.
Les clandestins camerounais
et afghans ont donc fait le même voyage.
À quelques semaines d'intervalle.
De Rome à Paris,
ils ont pris les mêmes trains,
admiré les mêmes paysages,
dormi dans les mêmes gares.
Mesdames et messieurs,
bonjour, vos chefs de bord
et l'équipe TGV vous souhaitent
la bienvenue à bord du TGV à destination
de Paris, gare de Lyon.
Habillés comme
des vacanciers, Afghans et Camerounais
n'ont attiré l'attention d'aucun
policier pendant tout leur trajet.
Enfin,
nous voici à Paris.
C'était notre rêve.
Maintenant, on y est.
Cette gare est impressionnante.
C'est sûrement
la plus grande du monde.
Maintenant, ils vont devoir
se fabriquer une nouvelle vie.
Et c'est là que
tout se complique.
Les choses ne sont pas aussi simples,
ni aussi évidentes qu'ils le pensent.
Au début,
tout le monde est joyeux.
Un ami d'enfance d'Élie,
arrivé il y a sept ans comme
étudiant, vient les accueillir.
Éli va dormir chez lui.
Pour Joseph aussi,
tout s'enchaîne bien.
Oui, nous sommes
à Marcadet actuellement.
Un vieux copain va l'héberger.
Il y a tous les bouchons
sur la route, mais il arrive.
Le seul à rester
sur le carreau, c'est Émile.
Aucune de ses connaissances
à Paris ne veut l'accueillir.
J'ai beaucoup de personnes ici
qui ont refusé de me recevoir.
Eric, le copain d'Élie,
tente de lui trouver une solution.
Au moins pour la nuit.
Je suis en train
d'appeler un cousin,
chez qui Émile pourra dormir.
Émile peut souffler.
Pour l'instant.
Ce soir, il aura un toit.
Mais demain ?
Quand nous avons arrêté le tournage,
Émile, Elie et Joseph,
les trois Camerounais,
n'étaient plus
hébergés par personne.
Lukman et Faouad, de leur côté,
se sont dirigés vers la seule adresse
qu'ils connaissent
un square parisien
bien connu
de leurs compatriotes.
Ici, il va y avoir plein d'Afghans.
On va voir du monde qu'on connaît
et même peut-être de notre famille.
Comme les Africains,
eux aussi, ont vite déchanté.
La vie de réfugiés à Paris
est loin d'être celle qu'ils imaginaient.
Il n'y a pas de travail
et personne pour les aider.
Heureusement,
leur nouveau copain leur livre
le mode d'emploi
pour survivre dans la jungle parisienne.
Si tu veux manger,
tu dois faire le tour des mosquées,
tu fais tes ablutions,
tes trois prières, tu auras un bon repas.
Le matin,
quand ce parc va ouvrir,
tu fais quoi à ton avis ?
Tu vas te chercher
un tapis et des cartons.
Et tu vas les poser ici.
Ton sac sera ton oreiller
et tu dormiras
juste pour ne pas penser.
On ne sait jamais
où on va manger le lendemain.
Notre situation est tellement mauvaise.
Ça fait
deux ans que je suis ici
et je n'ai pas encore
envoyé un centime au pays.
On m'avait dit qu'à Paris,
des hélicoptères aspergeaient
du parfum sur la ville.
Mais dès que je suis arrivé,
j'ai compris
que c'était pire que Djalalabad,
ma ville natale en Afghanistan.
Je n'aurais jamais pensé
que c'était comme ça.
On m'avait dit qu'à mon arrivée,
j'aurais tout, gare de l'Est.
Et puis là, je vois des gens
beaucoup plus malheureux que moi.
Alors, je fais quoi ?
Je reste ou je rentre ?
La nuit,
le square ferme ses portes.
Lukman et Faouad
partagent le sort des Afghans de Paris.
Quand je suis arrivé à Paris,
je croyais
que le gouvernement allait nous aider.
Et ici, je vois
mes frères afghans dormir dans la rue.
et mon rêve est totalement brisé.
Quatre mois après son départ
du Pakistan, Lukman erre dans Paris
en enchaînant
les centres d'hébergement et la rue.
Mais il apprend
le français dans une association.
Dégoûté,
Faouad a préféré tenter
sa chance en Allemagne.
Là-bas,
il s'est fait interpeller.
Il attend aujourd'hui,
que la justice allemande décide
de son sort.